for over four and a half billion years
the Sun has bathed our home planet
with light
it's bright stable glow helps life
flourish but hidden in the night sky
other planetary systems haven't been so
lucky hanging right above your head
every night we see up there these dead
corpses of stars 400 light-years from
Earth lies a system called SD SS j 12:28
a disk of debris orbits the faintly
glowing leftovers of a dead star J 1228
is a dead star it is the core of a star
that had aged blown off its outer layers
revealed the core which is about the
size of the earth but has about half the
mass of the star in it and we call these
white dwarfs May 2018
astronomers investigated Jay 1228 using
the world's largest optical telescope
the grand telescope EO Canaria s' they
discovered what appears to be a ball of
iron orbiting the white dwarf
the lump of metal less than 400 miles
across could be the exposed core of a
destroyed planet it's a clue to this
system's past what's always a little
poignant when you see evidence of a
planet around a dead star you know you
think back upon that star was shining
and could there have been life in that
solar system the J 1228 system is a
cosmic graveyard it might look different
than our solar system but this is our
future this discovery of a dead planet
orbiting a dead star is like looking
into a crystal ball and is it the future
of our own solar system yep
for a glimpse into your future you know
all you need to do is look up just like
Jay 12:28 our Sun will die killing off
earth in the process this terrifying
fate will play out across the galaxy in
a star apocalypse our Sun is a fairly
common type of star in the Milky Way and
so other stars in the Milky Way will
undergo the same sort of fate as the Sun
and will end up as white dwarfs and so
any other planets out there orbiting
sun-like stars will undergo a similar
fate
once the stars like our Sun have died
out what's gonna happen cuz I've still
survived around white dwarfs to
understand the fate of sun-like stars we
have to look inside them buried within
our clues to how they live and why they
die the core the very center that's
where the action is that's where the
star is fusing light elements into
heavier elements now it works like a
like a hydrogen bomb that's the same
thing if you compress hydrogen enough it
gets very hot and the pressure gets very
high and it fuses into helium and
generates energy heat and that's what's
happening in the core of every star
because of their enormous mass stars
have huge amounts of gravity this
gravity pushes inwards trying to
collapse the star but fusion energy from
the core stops that from happening it's
really this sort of very balanced dance
between gravity pushing in fusion energy
pushing out you can think of a star as
losing energy continuously to the
outside world and gravity is saying yes
I'm going to take over but no the
nuclear reactions inside a star
replenish the energy that's lost and
keep the star hot and pressurized inside
so the pressure gravity balance can be
maintained
this balance keeps sun-like stars alive
for up to 10 billion years until the
stars gas tank runs dry it's gonna run
out of fuel and when that happens it's
going to die but what is that going to
look like how is this gonna happen 100
million years ago things in the J 1228
system started to get ugly
first the star grew large really large
once the center starts fusing heavier
elements the outside will swell into
what will eventually be a red giant star
J 1228 transformed into a red giant its
outer layers blew off extending out over
40 million miles when stars like our Sun
die it's not a quiet affair it's very
violent and ugly and messy they turn
into red giants and they turn themselves
inside out and vomit all over the solar
system when J 1228 swelled into a red
giant nearby planets were stuck in a
kill zone the dying star engulfed them
or fried them with temperatures of over
1,200 degrees Fahrenheit atmospheres
disappeared oceans boiled away but one
planet survived J 1228 s death throes
here's a case where a planet survived in
some sense the death of its own star and
is still hanging around still hanging on
hoping for something new
the red giants expanding outer layers
separated from the stars core
with no active fusion the core collapsed
into a white dwarf the white dwarfs
dense gravity then went to work on the
one surviving planet compl anat that
might have been orbiting the normal star
can gradually spiral in toward the white
dwarf and then eventually the gravity of
the white dwarf pulls on the near side
of the planet more than on the far side
and that tears it apart what we're
seeing here is a dead star dining on its
own solar system
that's what is in the future for the Sun
J 1228 feasted on the remains of its
rocky world's leaving behind a disk of
debris and the planetary core it's a
glimpse of Earth's future what happened
here around this white dwarf is gonna
happen to earth is going to be stripped
of its atmosphere is crust and it's
mantle and the only thing that will
remain will be the core
fried and ripped apart by a dying star
not a good way to go
fortunately for life on earth our own
Sun isn't dying just yet the Sun is
middle-aged it's four-and-a-half billion
years old and it's gonna go on for
another five or six billion years we've
got a little bit of time before our Sun
pukes all over the solar system our home
planet may be safe for now but systems
like Jay 1228 show us that sun-like
stars are destined to die killing off
any life orbiting them but sun-like
stars aren't the only stars dying across
the cosmos there are others out there
and they're all doomed
there's a wonderful rainbow of stars out
there of all different shapes all
different sizes in all different colors
we're talking down to you know fractions
of the mass of the Sun up to hundreds of
times the mass of the Sun when it comes
to the star apocalypse size matters the
bigger and brighter the star the faster
it dies